Hmm.
Hey,
what's going on?
Is Bill burn his time for the Thursday afternoon?
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Ah,
just checking in on you.
Just seeing how your weeks go and how things are shaking out.
Jesus Christ.
If I get one more fucking tweak on pill,
what do you think of the Kyrie Irving for fucking Isaiah Thomas Trade?
What do I think?
I think Danny Ainge is known what the fuck he's doing up until now.
I think it's the trickle down effect of the Kevin Durant trade where you for
some reason can just not have enough fucking stars regardless of what your
players are doing.
Do you think that gave up too much?
Only time will tell.
I would tell.
I would say that I love,
uh,
Isaiah Thomas.
And what sucks about that trade was he was on his way to being like the fucking
big Papi of,
um,
of the Celtics.
Like he was going to have a frigging street named after him the way he was
going.
So it's a,
it's a real shame and a,
it was a,
just a great dude.
And,
uh,
I,
you know,
I don't know,
I just thought he was a,
he fit in real well with our city.
You know,
he was on his way to being a great Celtic I thought.
And um,
we gave a bunch of fucking people to get another guy who basically does the
exact same thing,
has the same amount of stuff.
I don't know.
He's a little bit bigger.
I don't know who the fuck knows.
All I know is the team that Isaiah succeeded with last year no longer exists
here.
So,
you know,
I don't know what the F I don't fucking know.
I hate all of this shit.
They gave up a first read Goodie from issue and the silver league,
like how the fuck you get into the NBA to that level or any sport you,
you need to get a fucking life when you start knowing what people fucking make
and all of that shit.
Like I don't,
I,
that's when I tap out.
It's just like,
oh,
we traded that guy for that guy.
We'll see what happens.
When does the season start in a couple of months.
Yeah.
I fucking think about it then either it's going to work or it's not going to
work.
Um,
there was a couple of Celtics fencing,
fucking so stupid.
They burned their Isaiah Thomas Jerseys.
Like he left the Celtics,
like he was doing some sort of free agent.
Fuck,
he got traded,
you'd dump fucks.
Um,
then of course everybody on Twitter tweets it to me and acts like this is every
Celtic fan and it isn't,
it isn't this always these fucking morons,
which is why I have been saying,
you know,
I would fucking,
I'm telling you right now,
this fucking Mayweather McGregor fight,
if he ever wanted to solve the population problem,
the amount of mouth breathers that are showing up.
Okay.
You send a fucking signal through the fucking bought whoever orders the fight
it,
you're done.
Yeah.
Something happens.
You know when they used to play in those old spy movies where they would play
that really high pitched fucking noise and people just grab their ears like,
and then they would die.
Yeah.
Do some star Trek Shit.
MMM.
That's going to go down is one of the biggest fucking rip offs of all fucking
time.
Mayweather,
Mcgregor.
Uh,
that's my prediction.
And if it doesn't,
I'll just say I was wrong and then I'll order the fight,
but there is no fucking way I'm going to sit there on Saturday night and watch a
guy who used to fucking box 1520 fucking years ago fight a guy who fucking
retired two years ago who's in his forties and everybody's asking,
acting like,
oh,
there's this to abuse first fucking law.
The guy's in his forties,
he's been retired for two years.
You remember when Jordan came back on the fucking wizards
taking two,
three fucking years off.
You know,
that was basketball.
Forget about boxing.
This is like the dumbest thing ever.
You know what it really is?
It's a bunch of fucking losers that want the,
you know,
the are unhappy with their own lives that want to see a guy that's been shooting
his mouth off saying is life is fucking great and they want to see him get
knocked on his ass and I'm so sick of people go,
it just spectacle.
It.
Just practical.
I'm just,
I'm tuning in for this spectacle.
Why are you using that word spectacle?
You fucking moron.
Because everybody on an in sports has been saying this since the amount of
fucking mouth breathing dopes that I've known,
you know,
and I'm one of them.
I've never heard him use the expression spectacle in my life.
Now it's like,
yeah,
just watch.
I'm watching it for the spectacle.
It's a spectacle.
A sport.
What does that mean exactly?
A spectacle.
You mean?
Is that like a fancy word for,
it's a fucking rip off.
These are the same people that would have paid fucking $60,
you know,
the equivalent of $60 30 fucking years ago,
40 years ago to watch lie ll Zeto fight fucking Muhammad Ali,
which actually happened if he never looked it up.
Alright,
spectacle.
Let's look up the definition of spectacle spectacle number one.
Uh,
something to stare at.
Number two,
a paper view.
Rip off now a visually striking performance or display.
Okay.
And invent or seen.
Regarded in terms of its visual impact.
I Dunno,
I dunno what's going on with sports right now or that,
that fucking league where they just take three people who used to be superstars
and played three other people that used to be superstars and a,
what do you get out of watching that half court,
a basketball confirmation that yes,
we are all going to die.
A slow death.
I'm sorry,
I'm really just being a scrooge.
Enjoy your fucking fight.
I will not be watching it.
I'm going to get out on the highway and drive like 80 miles an hour out here in
la,
you know,
and enjoy this city at the population that should be during that fucking fight.
There's so many more constructive things that I can fucking do.
And um,
this,
you know what it is?
Is it just doing this clearly for the fucking money and uh,
that's it.
So,
you know,
in a way it's,
I'm actually happy for him because they both get in their brains knocked out and
every fucking fight and God knows what's what their quality of life will be in
their fifties so good for them.
Go out and get your fucking money.
But I've given may whether it,
at least,
I dunno,
but his last seven fights times 6,420 bucks,
that he should return at least a portion of it.
He hasn't knocked any a buddy outs and said,
was it Ricky Hatton?
He fights fucking packy out 10 years after he should have the guy shows up with
the fucking injured shoulder.
He,
his singing voice is gone and he just fucking at it.
It's just,
I don't know.
All right.
I've,
I've said my piece.
You guys enjoy the fucking fight and uh,
you,
you text me your oh shits and whatnot.
Um,
afterwards,
first he was saying that pill.
It's a spectacle.
It's like,
dude,
I've known you for 10 years.
You've never said that word.
Um,
like they're above it.
Like they're above it.
I'm just watching her.
I,
you know,
I know it's bullshit.
I know.
It's like,
no,
dude,
you can't look away.
That's what's your fucking problem is people who are getting it just because all
we get is going to be so fucking ridiculous.
I this same fucking cons in front of you causing a traffic jam.
Because somebody is changing their tire on the side of the fucking road because
they can't look away and they will write behind all those other costs,
screaming at him,
go,
go drive.
And then the second they come up to it,
they're sitting there fucking rubber neck.
All right there.
I'm telling you,
you know what the human population is like,
the human population is like a fucking a,
okay.
You know,
you know those fucking movies that Hollywood always makes,
you know with a white person goes into like the fucking inner city and then goes
in and turns everybody's fucking life around and everybody becomes successful in
all of those.
Nobody fucks it up.
Right.
That's what the world population is like.
It's like that teacher is running shit,
you know,
can't make the cuts that he needs to make to get down to the fucking real NFL
roster.
Does it make any fucking sense?
I'm just saying that it's just too big a heart.
I hate those fucking feels fucking movies by the way.
Okay.
You know,
with a white person goes into the area with his no white people and then save
shit and they never addressed the fact that white people caused the situation.
You know,
and then we turn ourselves into the hero
so then white people can go see the movie.
It'd be like,
damn,
that's the white person I be in that scenario.
Well Buddy,
you could go fucking do it.
There's plenty of schools that need fucking hero white guy to go down to to try
to help out.
You know what it is right now.
I'm fucking on a rant right now just because I fucking,
you know Neil Neil loves those God damn award shows and all of these fucking
liberal constant go up on there and they talk about dolphins,
you know,
and they blog will blend.
They use their celebrity as a shine a light on it before they go back to their
fucking gated community.
It's like,
why don't you get your hands dirty,
you know,
get your hands dirty or shut the fuck up and you're fucking Louis Vuitton
Tuxedo.
Whatever the hell it is you're doing.
Why am I in such a mood?
You know what it is.
I didn't sleep well last night.
And,
uh,
these fucking,
I dunno why this army of bugs bit the shit out of my left ankle.
Um,
and it's on fire and off.
It was a spider.
I don't know what the hell it was,
but my whole fucking foot turn red,
you know,
and it's something back in the day before I had a kid,
my wife would help me out with,
but now we have a kid.
So,
you know,
I've gone down on the depth chart,
something like,
Dan,
let's have a look at my fucking foot.
She's like,
Jesus Christ,
I got,
do we have anything for that?
And she's like,
yeah,
I think we do.
Okay.
That's it.
I'm like,
ah.
Do you know what it is?
Uh,
some aloe fucken Moose,
you can put some Mousse on it.
I Dunno.
So I had been dealing with,
she claims that,
you know,
as you know,
the doctor that she isn't claims that it's getting better.
I Dunno.
All I know is a,
you know,
I'm talking to you guys with a really fucking itchy foot,
so maybe that's what it is.
Um,
oh man,
that's going to be fucking exciting.
I'm going to actually get to experience what people experience who don't give a
shit about sports on the super bowl.
You get to fucking cruise around the city,
get a bunch of errands done,
you know,
ride a bicycle right down the middle of the street.
Yeah,
this is a bad podcast,
everybody,
if you're not reefing not really aware of it.
At this point,
I started off negative and I wasn't even more negative.
Um,
is anybody else sick of that fucking guy in the Lakers,
dad already?
Jesus Christ.
It's like he made it to the NBA.
You're going to get your money.
All right,
enough with the fucking carnival barking.
I would make Michael Jordan cry if I played him one on one.
Was that the weirdest interview?
I just saw a clip of it.
Jimmy Kimmel is literally talking over the guy who,
who's actually going to go into the NBA to talk to the guy who never made it to
the NBA,
who's sitting there.
He's talking about how he's going to beat Michael Jordan.
And the other is sitting there like a scolded child that looked like a fucking
parents teacher meeting.
[inaudible] um,
tell me that isn't a 30 for 30.
And when he goes to finally make his break from his overbearing father,
um,
all right,
there's another negative thing.
All right,
where else?
Where else can we go with negativity?
You got anything positive to say?
Ah,
yes.
I finally have committed to not drinking after false advertising of Billy.
No fun months ago.
I can only go three,
four days.
I have now put together a run of seven days of come back up from triple.
I'm want a little bit of a heat hitting streak right now and I've gone seven
days.
And,
um,
I love it in the morning,
not drinking in the morning is the greatest at night.
It's been,
uh,
it's been a little bit of a,
you know,
it's a fucking habit I have to break,
but I think,
you know,
once I get up to like seven to 10 days,
then I'm like,
it literally go for a year.
It's weird.
It's just getting to that,
you know,
starting to drop some weight.
I've been jumping on the ellipticals,
uh,
I've been fucking working out my a rotator cup feels a little bit better and a,
what I do at night is I just got to go play drums and then I go do a standup set
that a couple of sets last night played some fucking trumps.
And uh,
you know,
it's weird above playing drums or an instrument is the more you learn,
the more you realize you suck.
And it's just really frustrating.
You know,
it's almost like he's just learn everything you can to learn,
stop learning,
get all that shit down.
Considering I'm never going to play in a band.
I'm not going to pursue this professionally.
Then I could actually sit behind a kit and be like,
happy with what I'm fucking doing.
I have learned to tune up a snare.
I can get it sound really good,
but my bass drum sounds like shit,
there's always something.
So he's fucking something.
Let's read some advertising here.
Maybe if I read advertising,
this will get me out of this negative four tech that I've fucking gone into.
Um,
Jesus in 13 and a half minutes.
Yeah,
just negative.
You know what's funny is what I should really be,
I should really be rooting for this McGregor Mayweather fight to be a great
thing.
Cause then I can,
I can rent it and then,
and I'll get to watch something interesting,
but I'm s I so want to be right about this,
you know,
you're not going to get me right.
I'm the Guy Walking,
you know,
driving by who wants to look,
but I'm not going to look to prove some sort of point that nobody in front of me
behind me or next to me is going to give a shit about,
that's basically what I'm doing with this.
Um,
anyways,
prediction on the fight.
Yes.
Uh,
I to say Mcgregor's not going to be,
and you know,
I don't know.
It's two years ago.
If he's anything like he used to be Mcgregor's not gonna be able to lay a
fucking hand on him.
Why anybody would think that McGregor could lay a fucking glove on Mayweather
whether fucking beyond me,
unless they,
unless he got really old in the last two years.
And let's it's Jordan from the bowls to the wizards.
And if,
if it's that type of leap,
yes,
Mcgregor has a fucking shot,
but then who gives a shit?
He beats up a fucking guy,
you know,
two years after he retired,
imagine not going to the gym for two years.
Okay.
Then fucking check.
You know,
race and somebody down the street for a fucking mile.
Me undies are,
but it'll doe doe beyond ease beyond these.
Oh,
bill is a negative con.
Oh dude too.
To be on the shut 'em up if you want.
I'm sorry.
A youtube can look good in your underwear and be comfortable.
Right?
Okay.
No,
you want to look good in your underwear.
Be Comfortable.
Right.
But that perfect balance is hard to find.
Don't sacrifice style a comfort.
Checkout [inaudible] dot com and find the best pair of underwear in the world
world,
world.
Talk about me undies and it's the best underwear you will ever own.
Well,
first of all,
they sent it to me for free.
Second of all,
it's fucking cottony soft,
but three times more.
So you know,
in late at night,
no,
my wife goes to bed,
my daughter's sleeping and everybody's quiet.
My balls talk to me and they say thank you bill.
Thank you for getting me undies beyond.
And these will be the most comfortable pair of underwear you will ever own.
Made from a sustainably sourced natural soft fabric fabric that is three times
softer than cotton.
For the fellas beyond these diamond seen pouch cradles your jewels,
Largo,
rag,
stone ball bag,
and gives you your stuff and give you stuff to support it.
It needs without feeling too tight.
Ladies will love the soft ecofriendly fabric for their twats.
They're so soft and touchable,
gross,
a hundred percent satisfaction guarantee.
The guarantee you will love your undies or your money back for whatever reason.
There's still another three paragraphs here,
aren't you guys sold at this point?
Okay.
And the Andes is so sure you'll love their underwear.
They will even offer,
well,
100% satisfaction guarantee.
You order a pair and if you don't like your first pair of get a full refund and
fucking throw it out the window at a homeless guy.
I'm not the money,
the underwear,
you keep the money.
All right.
This no brainer.
This is a no brainer to try 20% off free Andy's and a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee.
What are you waiting for to get you 20% off and free shipping?
A hundred percent satisfaction guarantee and they get the best softest underwear
you will ever own.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash bar there's let me time offer.
This is a limited time offer.
So what are you waiting for?
Start wearing the best underwear of your life.
It changed my life evidently.
Yeah,
it did.
Cause I got to sing the song in a,
I got more advertising from it.
It's time to let me undies change yours.
Go to me undies.com/bar right now.
Okay.
Oh,
we only have two reeds.
Oh my God,
I love it.
Legal Zoom,
everybody.
It's national.
Make a will month at legal zoom,
and that means it's time to take control of your family and assets.
Preparing your family's future is the most important thing you'll do this
summer.
It's the most in fucking thing you could ever do.
All right?
All the time.
People die in car accidents.
They drop a heart attacks a fucking piano falls and that God damn had all these
young guys.
Their wife fucking nags him to death through an early fucking grave and they do
not have a will or a trust or any of that shit.
And then all the fucking evil people show up.
Hm,
let's start claiming that they were your best friend and they tried to take all
your shit and,
and the money away from your kids.
You have to fucking do it.
It's something that guys don't like to do,
dealing with their own mortality,
which is probably why I'm not going to watch Mayweather come in.
The fact that I could actually watch a guy who does not box for a fucking
living,
possibly beat the best boxer of all time.
All that's going to mean is that,
yeah,
Bill,
everybody dies.
I don't need to watch that.
I don't need to watch the big three,
the big three coming out there and they're fucking walkers playing each other
and nobody can dunk anymore.
I'm sure somebody can dunk their fucking nine feet tall,
but I'm just saying,
all right,
men do not like to deal with that shit.
All right?
But,
uh,
this is,
you got to fame.
You got a fair way,
man.
You got to fucking deal with this stuff.
All right,
so go to legal zoom.com/burr prepare to get your free kit.
You'll get a ton of helpful information,
plus legal zoom discounts,
all the things you need,
uh,
to stop procrastinating and start preparing for your family's future.
Legal Zoom designed the kit to provide the tools you need all in one place.
Whether a will or a trust
is right for you.
What the fuck's wrong with my voice?
Not Drinking.
I'm not smoking.
Uh,
you'll get special legal zoom discounts plus an estate plan checklist and ebook
and other information to help you decide out of the fucking blue.
And if you have any more questions,
you can always get advice from their network of attorneys available in all 50
states since legal zooms,
not a law firm.
That's the guy I did all of this shit.
Okay?
And I didn't want to do it cause I didn't want to deal with me,
Diane and all of this shit.
What do you want to do when you died?
You want to be cremated,
put in the ground and all this shit.
I got to tell you,
when I was done with it,
it was like a weight was off my shoulders and my chest.
I mean,
because every time I'd get on a flight,
you know,
I'd always think of this fucking thing goes down right now.
What's going to happen to my wife and kid?
You know what I mean?
Go to legal zoom.com/prepare today.
There's no obligation,
just great resources to help you protect everything you you care about during
national.
Make a will month.
That's legalzoom.com/prepare all right,
now it's time to talk about my real feelings about them.
Mayweather,
Mcgregor fight.
I am curious.
I do want to watch,
but I've just been burned too many fucking times.
So what I'm doing is I'm letting you guys take the beach.
All right?
And if you tweet at me all my God,
that was fucking amazing.
[inaudible] going to lie to me.
I'll go on the internet and if everybody said that was amazing and it was worth
the fucking money,
I will then rent the fight.
That's what I'm doing from now on.
Cause I've just,
I've just been burned too many fucking times.
Um,
I think it will be devastating for boxing if Mayweather loses,
even though he's been retired for two fucking years.
Um,
basically it's all about the first couple of rounds.
If Mcgregor's going to do it,
if he doesn't do it within fucking three rounds,
he's fucked.
That's it.
Okay.
There's my brilliant insight.
I know what everybody else knows.
I have to watch too many McGregor's fights any imminent.
When he would fight Nate,
he get into the fourth round and he would be winded.
So they fight five minute rounds.
So I didn't,
I don't know.
I think even though they only fight what,
how many [inaudible] how many minutes or there's a three minute rounds,
right?
So logically you'd be the,
well,
five minutes in then,
then that's the equivalent to go in five rounds.
I mean,
three rounds,
five minute rounds in the fucking UFC.
Jesus Christ belt.
But here's the thing,
he's going to be using different muscles.
You know,
he's going to waste a lot of fucking energy trying to hit somebody that nobody
could fucking hit.
And um,
I dunno,
I dunno what it is,
but they're both brilliant fucking fighters,
stip,
both amazing.
And,
uh,
they're also,
you know,
they're as good at selling a fight,
which is why everybody's showing up in all of that shit because too big shit
talkers,
you know,
there's nothing people like better than seeing a shit talker lose and one of
them's going to lose.
So I guess that's why everybody's going to watch,
but I cannot fucking resist.
Okay.
D,
uh,
the euphoria of not doing what everybody else is doing and getting to do other
shit.
It's something I learned when I would watch the super bowl and I would just take
the fucking thing
and just do other shit for the first 90 minutes of the game.
So I can fast forward through all of the commercials and the absolutely fucking
horrific halftime show and the opening ceremonies and all of that other
bullshit.
And I could just watch the Goddamn game.
I remember when I would drive around and go,
you know,
okay,
get something to eat or some shit and they'd just be nobody on the fucking road.
And you just get to experience what you city was like back before there were
automobiles sub,
you're in a car and there's paved roads.
I Dunno,
there's this sort of a,
uh,
I kind of understand a little bit like why people don't watch sports.
I actually get it now like the amount of free time and if you like,
but the thing is is you've got to fill that free time up.
It was like some healthy shit.
Oh,
this is like a nice ying and Yang total negative.
Now I'm going to go positive.
Just imagine.
Okay.
First of all,
a the food you wouldn't eat.
All right?
All the extra time you'd have to work out.
You know,
if you always wanted to learn how to play guitar and learn how to speak a
language,
the amount of time you spend,
you know,
I can't say wasting your time because you enjoy it.
I fucking enjoy it.
Right.
If you're a sports fan,
but just think of everything that you could accomplish.
I remember like one of the first times the NFL went on strike in my life
and they went in and when it would come back,
you know,
they showed a couple people on the news and I don't know if they were lying or
whatever.
They were just like,
yeah man,
you know,
I'm Kinda,
it was Kinda cool to have like Saturday and Sunday in the fall to myself.
I can hang out with my kids.
I can go do some shit.
I just don't give a fuck anymore.
Um,
okay.
I don't know.
This weird part of me.
I can't stop watching it then.
This is part of me that I wish I,
I wish I could do it.
But then you just fill it up with something else dumb.
Then it become one of those what comic con people
that knows the actor's name that crunched down in that r two d two fucking
thing.
That little fucking trash compactor that he was riding around in.
I Dunno.
Do you know what all of this shit,
it's,
it's bigger than me.
I have no idea what any of these fucking shit means.
Enjoy.
You got damn fight.
Don't let's do a crabby freckled bald cont like me telling you that it's a
fucking rip off you go enjoy your goddamn spectacle.
Yeah.
You deserve it.
It's a spectacle.
Donald Trump isn't enough of a fucking spectacle.
That's not enough for you,
Jesus Christ.
Do you know I don't even,
I don't even fuck that.
That's something like,
I pay attention to that.
I don't pay attention to that.
The way somebody does who doesn't give a fuck about sports pays attention to it.
Um,
the fact that our president tweets and reads is his Twitter account.
It's just,
I don't,
I don't even know like,
okay.
It's like,
dude,
you were above that.
You're above it.
Fucking respond.
I don't,
you don't meet people shit on me.
I don't even,
I feel,
I don't even need to respond to people shitting on me.
I,
first of all,
I feel it's par for the course.
Not Everybody's going to like you.
The fact that this fucking guy's got to go on and responsive.
What are you doing?
But then again,
he did win it.
He won that.
He won the whole fucking,
I love people who think he's dumb.
It's like if he's that fucking stupid.
How did all those smart people lose to them?
That was like back in the day when that the woman Jessica Simpson,
when she would be like chicken of the sea.
Is that like chicken or is it tuna?
Okay.
Which to be honest,
looking back was a legit question.
I mean it is a food and he wrote chicken on it.
That's like chicken fried steak for years though.
So is it chicken is at stake.
What the fuck is it?
Yeah.
Hey,
take a ride in my truck car.
What the fuck is it?
Why would you call it something else when it says,
um,
everybody thought she was dumb.
It's like,
yeah.
Yeah.
She's a fucking moron with,
with hit albums in our own TV shows.
Like,
I would love to be that stupid.
Okay.
You know she married Nicholas Shea.
He's a good looking fella,
right guys.
Guys in a boy band.
He plays golf on the fucking weekend.
She was crushing it.
Date and Tony Romo.
Robo Robo.
Did she marry him?
I don't know.
I feel bad for a one day.
Like,
I think it was her.
She,
her little dog,
you know,
like last seen in the mouth of a coyote.
It's like,
yeah,
it's fucking dead.
MMM.
What do you think the coyotes have like some sort of terrorist group and they're
going to fucking you UB duck your dog and change it's fucking mindset.
It's going to be like the patty Hearst to fucking chihuahuas.
No,
it's,
it's dead.
That's why you got to get a big dog out here.
You got to have a big dog that liked the other coyotes or like,
you know what,
it's not fucking worth it.
You know what I mean?
Like for dogs out here,
this is like going to fucking Rikers island.
All right,
well you need a big need to be a big fucking muscular goddamn dog.
You need to be more of a fucking problem.
Then these little fellas out here,
these little dogs like,
I dunno what people do,
like they fucking leave him in their backyards and shit and they just,
they just did gone.
They're gone.
It's like,
it's like literally like one of those creepy fucking movies.
You know where they would,
you know,
the people would go to an island and they were just living with some sort of
dragon or some sort of gorilla and they would just sacrifice somebody like King
Kong and that type of shits of this fucking thing,
but leave him alone.
That's such a weird beginning,
Huh?
To the King Kong movie,
that poor woman's like tied up with those fucking vines and I just don't get
like,
okay,
you got a 60 foot God damn gorilla.
He's going to eat that fucking won
one person and they'd be like filled up.
That's going to be like Doritos,
right?
Well not Doritos because we're mostly fucking,
you know,
protein and shit.
We're kind of a protein snack.
We right till that's like Kymab and like a Clif bar.
Goddamn 60 foot is going to eat one clif bar every couple of months and then be
fine.
First of all,
I didn't think gorillas,
I thought they were vegetarians,
right?
I thought they sat around just fucking eating.
I don't know what the hell they,
there's always some fucking person got to go try and live with them and get a
little closer and a little closer
and then eventually get the shit kicked out of them
by the God damn gorilla.
I gotta tell you,
man,
the amount of shit that a gorilla we'll put up with it because it's as big as it
is.
I wonder if a gorilla has ever fought like a tiger and for that we need to go to
Asia.
You know you want to talk about spectacles where you have a boxer against an MMA
guy,
like agents.
I'm telling you,
if you want to go see any,
anytime you start looking at like this versus this,
this versus that,
you will find black and white footage where they put a fucking bear and a tiger
in the same cage to see what our line,
we're against the tire just to see what the fuck would happen.
Um,
they did it.
That's their thing
where we experimented with human beings.
They experimented with animals.
It seems I don't fuck why,
what am I even talking?
But you know,
this is one of these podcasts where it just started off on the wrong foot head.
Now I'm just desperately trying fill the last 18 seconds of this thing so I can
get up to fucking my contractually obligated 30 minutes.
How about those red sox aren't taking two out of three at a Teray.
Terry Francona is fucking a team there.
The Cleveland Indians,
um,
piling up the fucking numbers there.
I haven't been keeping up on what the,
uh,
the Yankees are doing.
So why don't I try to end this thing on something positive?
You guys enjoy your fight,
your sports spectacle.
This,
uh,
this weekend,
I hope you don't get fucked over.
And I'm,
I'm being honest.
You know something.
I'm going to be a bigger man here rather than being the guy that said,
I told you so.
I hope on Monday you guys can all come back and I can read a bunch of fucking
letters of like,
Bill,
you negative cont you've never been wrong.
More wrong in your freckled pathetic life.
And a,
I really hope that you guys are able to send those to me.
I hope you make it.
Hope you get your money's worth.
Um,
like I said,
I will not be watching the fucking thing.
Um,
I'm too God damn stubborn.
All right.
I,
you know something,
I'm actually,
this is,
this is actually for me,
this pay per view is about being able to walk away because I've jumped on the
fucking,
you know,
the UFC has done that to me.
You have [inaudible] I've ordered the fucking shit and then find out somebody
tested positive for steroids.
You know,
UFC is also doing that shit now.
Now that they got bought out by other fucking people,
you know,
and Dana White's like the figurehead.
No.
However,
the,
how the fuck it works that doing that shit.
Now we're like,
every three pounds is a new way class.
So now they have all these air quote champions.
So then everything's a fucking championship fight.
That's like what fucking killed boxing aside from the fact that they had like 50
different goddamn leagues or whatever,
the WBA,
the WBC,
the IBF,
they was like three heavyweight champions all at the same time.
And then somebody had to try to come in and unify the titles.
Um,
yeah.
And like then,
like every,
like eight pounds became like a fucking weight class or whatever.
I only know it was,
everything was like a title fight and they were,
they weren't as good.
So I hope to,
UFC doesn't go that route because,
um,
what was great when they had the monopoly was a,
the best fought,
the best soil.
Hope that continues.
Um,
I apologize for this podcast everybody.
I don't know why I'm shitting on everything.
That's just fun.
Simple God damn fun in this miserable world.
Why would I do that?
All right,
come on bill.
Pull it out of the mud.
This fight is going to be the greatest spectacle of all time.
If you do not put $60 down on that,
you are going to miss out,
right?
There you go.
That was positive.
What do you want from me?
I tried,
I tried.
I got an Itchy foot and my fucking body is like reacting to the fact,
you know,
if anyone else is,
um,
a couple of my friends,
uh,
became parents,
right?
So what I always do,
my gift that I do is I go out and I buy a nice,
cute,
cool pair of fucking sneakers,
right?
Little Jordans will uptown's whatever the fuck you want,
That's what I get for the kid.
Okay.
And then I get to sick bottles of fucking booze for the parents.
You know,
because here's the deal.
Everybody's,
I think I already told you the day everybody's going to go out and go buy a
stuffed fucking animal,
this fucking thing.
And it's just going to be this thing that the parents,
the kid can't fucking use it.
It's a baby to Goddamn blob that you carry around for fucking three months.
All right.
And then when we finally can move around,
it Wa it doesn't give a shit about toys.
All right?
It likes extension cords.
It likes pots and pans.
It likes you just any fucking thing that it shouldn't be touching.
That's what it wants.
And he could give a fuck about the Goddamn toys.
Buying a toy for a baby is the biggest,
it's a bigger waste of money than buying this Conor McGregor Mayweather fight
this weekend.
I just can't get out of it.
People.
Um,
I feel like the libertarian this weekend,
you know,
is actually addressing the problem with a Democrat and the Republican would back
one of the two candidates and act like it's going to change your life and that
this was going to be a good thing for you.
And I'm the fucking the fucking Green party guy going,
hey man,
he's bankers.
You over me and everybody's bought and paid for me.
MMM.
You want a Brussels sprout and of account of sandwich man.
Um,
but the parents,
everybody fee immediately,
immediately.
Now that you have a kid like you,
you go down on the depth chart and nobody gives a shit about you.
Everybody cares about the kid.
Right?
Which is great.
That's the way it should be.
But if you actually do something for the parents,
okay.
And actually acknowledged that they are individuals with hopes and dreams that
have now been dashed because all of their focus is now going on the baby,
which is the way it should be.
But every once in a while you've got to throw him a fucking needle ginger snap
there.
Right.
So that's what I do.
I go out,
I buy a sick ass bottle of booze and a nice bottle for the guy in a fucking nice
bottle of Rozay for the lady.
And then I just get the kid a pair of shoes,
sneakers,
cool sneakers for when the kids walk in and they can actually use those things,
you know,
as opposed to some stupid fucking thing.
You know that they're supposed to reach up and grab whatever the fuck it is.
That's what I do.
Okay,
there you go.
Anyways,
fucking,
I got like the hiccups,
my foot itches and I'm off the sauce.
I'm off to sauce and I'm going back to Boston this week and I'm staying off the
sauce.
I had been working out and I'm staying off the fucking sauce.
Um,
I already,
I already had the conversations in my head.
I'm not fucking doing it.
I'm going to go on a nice,
nice run here.
I am a committed to it.
I'm dropping some fucking pounds.
So that's it.
Um,
enjoy your guys' fight this weekend.
I hope you get your money's worth.
I've said that 50 times trying to make up for the fucking previous negative 30
minutes.
Uh,
that's the podcast for this Thursday afternoon.
Have a great weekend.
You constant joy.
This music and then we got to throw back podcasts.
Mothers' Thursday,
I dunno,
from last year,
the year before,
maybe a couple of weeks ago.
Who knows.
All right,
I'll see you later.
Watching the whites of your eyes to the
world.
He's been reading some
thing.
How much you change all the money
back those days.
Yep.
All right.
Girlfriend in fantasy league.
Yeah.
Hey Bill,
love the podcast.
I'll put up the,
thank you.
I've been in a fantasy football league for 10 years.
It was started by one of my best friends and has been the same 12 guys for a
decade.
I don't even know how bands had put,
uh,
I don't even know bands that have been together that long.
So this year my buddy who started the league decided to boot out to lifelong
members in favor of his girlfriend
and the girlfriend
of a friend of ours.
Wait a minute.
Wait.
Sit.
Those other two guys who got booted,
did they anything,
okay.
Um,
if he was going to add the ladies,
why did those other two guys have to leave?
Okay.
Wow.
All right.
Okay.
Well I'm sucked into this story.
He said I immediately called Bullshit and said point blank to his face and she
wasn't sucking your Dick then she wouldn't be in the league.
Uh,
dude,
that right there is a game changer.
You can't say,
what if he marries this woman?
Always.
There's a roofie guys.
Always be careful what you say about the woman you're guy is with.
Cause you never fucking know.
You never know.
And I'm sure there's some listeners that have stories and if you'd like to
contribute them to the podcast where uh,
you know it's even fucking worse is when
your buddy,
he says fucked up shit about the girl.
You know about what a horse she is in bed and she's fucking his brains out,
but blah,
blah blah,
blah,
Blah and tells you all these these details and then the jackass ends up falling
for and then he has to fucking break up with you because he's not going to break
up with her because every time he looks at you he thinks out.
You know,
he,
he knows how this girl,
my future wife's sucks my Dick,
you know.
Anyways,
plowing ahead.
He's trying to defend this decision by saying she at least knows a little about
sports.
So this is awful.
Okay.
This guy wasn't raised right,
man.
This is just,
this is fucking terrible.
You said the fact of the matter is that she is from New York and knows who the
jets are.
That's the extent of her football knowledge.
He thinks I'm overreacting,
not overreacting.
Okay.
He didn't ask anybody else.
You've had 12 for the last 10 years and he just removed two of the original band
members,
so this isn't even funny.
This is,
this is really upsetting to me.
He thinks I'm overreacting,
but I think of it the same scenario.
If you had,
if you have one night a year to have a guy's night with your buddies and then he
gets to the bar,
you see that your friend has invited his girlfriend to guys night.
Exactly.
Even told me that she,
she's the one who asked if she could join,
which obviously to me means he had no intentions of inviting her,
but when he was backed into the corner,
his ball shot up into his throat and he couldn't say no.
Exactly.
It's not just a fantasy league,
but a clear indication that she's going to slowly start chipping away at
everything else in the rest of his life.
Exactly.
In summation,
his girlfriend wanted in and he crumbled and said,
yes.
Am I reading too much into this?
Am I overreacting?
I'd like to know because he's getting pissed at me for being pissed at him.
Absolutely not,
sir.
Everything that I was going to tell you,
you already know.
And you wrote in this email,
okay?
You ran down the mats,
you went off the little fucking springboard.
Do you hit the fucking hobby horse?
You dead.
Your little fucking Mary Lou Leighton Flip and you stuck the landing.
You get a perfect 10 on that one,
sir.
You are 100% right.
You know what you want.
My move would be,
I would start my own fantasy league.
All right?
And I would invite everybody else in that fucking leak.
Well,
I wouldn't do that cause now that's,
that's a chick move.
Make people decide,
oh,
this is what I,
I wouldn't be as harsh with him and just be like,
no.
Do what you did was absolute bullshit.
And I guarantee you,
I would tell them that she's going to start chipping away with you and your
life.
Your balls are up in your throat.
Um,
but that's going to end your friendship with them.
But here's the deal,
dude.
There are other fantasy football leagues.
Did join.
All right.
And uh,
that,
that's one of those ugly things about
that chapter of guys lives after,
um,
college.
You know,
when you went to grade school together or you met them and call up guys in
college or whatever,
but you guys have this unbelievable bond,
like you went to fucking war together.
MMM.
If one of your friends is a pussy,
you know,
he has,
um,
he has a chance of meeting somebody who's going to splinter that group.
You know,
and this isn't an anti woman thing,
this is more like an anti pussy guy kind of thing where raw,
you know,
there are controlling,
suffocating people on both sides.
Men and women.
And I know that there's women listening and they've,
one of their best girlfriend started dating some fucking overbearing,
insecure Douche bag guy.
And the first thing they do is they cut them off from their friends and then
it's the coworkers,
then the friends and then their family,
they stick them under a fucking
little glass or something.
So,
uh,
yeah,
you know what dude?
You're the worst.
The sad thing is,
is you're going to lose a couple of friends.
Sometimes that happens and a,
you just have to be content about it.
And
you know,
and I think it's really important for men and women to have men only and women
only social events that they can go to once a week or a couple of times a month
and just hang out with the fellows and hang out with the ladies.
It just,
whatever.
I think it's really,
really healthy.
It's gives you something to look forward to.
It gives you a place where you could just vent about your anything you fucking
want.
And in a group of people,
that 100% is going to understand it.
You don't have to worry about hurting anybody's feelings or offending on
anybody.
I think it's true.
It's really,
really fucking healthy.
And this guy's fucking with that.
And uh,
and he didn't put it to a vote.
What is he?
The Grand Poobah this shit.
I Dunno.
There's so many ways you can go with that to spending,
depending on how much you want to stir up the pot.
You guys should put it to the vote.
This,
it'd be great.
Put it to a vote.
Do it.
Have this be like you're Arab spring,
but with a fantasy football league and just fault that cunt out and then you
become the dictator and you move into the palace.
How about that?
What happened?
Dude,
you're 100% right.
I would just,
I would choose my words a little more carefully.
Don't say that you didn't have the balls.
Just say,
listen,
this was something that we did together for 12 years and
uh,
I'm really disappointed and shocked that you made this big a move and remove two
other members and didn't include anybody else.
It,
I don't think that it was done right and I think we should put this to a vote.
That's what we should do.
And if he gets mad and he starts yelling,
don't lose your cool.
Just keep stating your opinion calmly and you know,
if he's going to be a bitch about it,
let it be a bitch about it.
And I would actually,
for your own health,
did she already thinks she knows is the jet she's gonna be like,
wait a minute.
Who is this
fat?
I have my God,
I don't know anything.
She's
try to do that.
You know that thing where women try to act like they're dumb because they think
it's cute.
You know what I would do,
sir?
I would just plant your losses just fucking with,
I don't know.
The more I think about it,
the more noise I'm getting to just ruined my fucking day and I'm not even in it.
I don't even like fantasy football.
Cool.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and this is the Monday morning podcast.
So Monday,
August 24th,
2009.
How the hell are you,
uh,
another week going by.
I got a big week coming up here.
Really excited.
I'm actually going to Sweden this week and I really wanted to read a lot about
Sweden.
I want him to know a couple of the phrases,
you know,
the ones that you need to know.
Uh,
something about where can I get something to eat?
How to say thank you and how to say,
dude,
do me a favor.
Why don't you get the fuck away from me?
You know,
cause you're kind of freaking me out.
I mean,
you need,
you need to know how to say that in every language and your real,
that's the one that you really need to memorize.
Okay?
So you can,
it was some feeling,
you know what I mean?
You can't be like,
ah Dude,
get the fuck me away.
You know,
you,
you gotta you gotta you just gotta come.
I dude,
get the fuck away from me.
I'm serious.
I'm not kidding.
Get the fuck away from it.
He got to,
you'd have to know how to say that.
And I have no idea.
I'm not gonna lie to you.
All I know about Sweden is that fucking puppet on a,
the muppet show.
Remember that one?
Borghi [inaudible] Borg who are Geeky dish mortgage ED board
workbook.
Here we have to heat ish.
Muti
remember that.
That's all I know.
You know,
is it Sweden?
The one where they cross country ski to school.
I know Hitler.
You still look at it across the waters.
Start jerking off,
wishing he was blond and blue eyed.
You know
the fucking poor bastard.
Not only did he not,
well,
not only was he not blonde and blue eyed,
he couldn't even get a chance.
He just,
he couldn't,
his girlfriend wasn't even blonde and blue eyed.
You know what I mean?
I'm going to put this out here at LACC.
I know there's been a ton of shit out there on Hitler.
Um,
I'm going to put this out here.
This is a theory that I have.
I think Hitler had no game with women.
You know,
women don't like angry guys.
Psychos do psychos,
like hangry guys.
You know,
I was actually talking to this bird last night and she was saying how,
I don't know what the fuck her boyfriend does buy it.
Ah,
she was saying up until this point,
like the guy she's dating now,
this is the first time she's a not dated someone who's a musician and she was
just high.
And I just always like musicians.
The Oh,
the passion they have on stage and they're crazy.
And your guy,
your guy.
And I was really sitting there listening to her.
She described dating musician.
I realized that at,
for a female,
that's the,
that's the female equivalent of a dating.
A stripper is if you date a musician,
it's the same fucking thing.
You know,
they're on stage,
they're sweaty,
they're on drugs,
they're bad with money.
And in the end you have to take care of them.
You got ended up being a fucking parent.
Wow.
That's really fucking came together,
doesn't it?
Jesus Christ.
It's not bad.
Right?
Cleo,
look at Jesus Christ.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
let's plow ahead here.
We've got it.
We've got a lot of shit.
So anyways,
I had this,
this,
this great week.
I did this benefit.
How funny is this?
Cause,
uh,
if you guys listened to my podcast last week,
I had that incident with that woman from the humane society,
right?
So this week talk about irony.
I actually had a gig where I was doing a benefit for a four rescue dogs and it
was kind of the usual thing where I'm sitting in my head going,
fuck,
I hate doing benefits.
I can't stand to a benefit.
My Act,
I don't want it.
I don't have any jokes that do well at benefits.
I just don't,
there's always like,
they always put me on and there's a bunch of Nice comics in front of me or even
if they're not nice,
that be a nice,
and then I go up there and I try to be nice and you guys all know I'm a cunt.
So,
you know,
you can't,
I can't get that conti tone out of my voice and I just always end up feeling
crass and ignorant.
I just,
I hate doing them.
Right.
But fortunately,
this was actually a great gig.
And the,
uh,
the dude host and the show,
you know,
he was bringing up all these,
uh,
the celebrity people.
And,
uh,
I don't know if I should tell this story,
but I'm gonna just cause I don't think that many people listen to this podcast.
One of the people who went up there was a,
was Priscilla Presley,
you know,
uh,
Elvis's girlfriend,
wife or whatever and all that type of stuff.
So she's up there talking about how,
uh,
some ridiculous amount of puppies every year get killed,
you know,
at shelters and get put down like over a million puppies every year above and
says really serious moment.
And you know,
she was dressed,
she looked beautiful and everything.
And,
uh,
I'm standing back there with another couple of people and,
Geez,
I really shouldn't tell this story because it involves other people.
Okay,
fuck it.
This is what comics do in that situation as everyone else.
All you normal people who can get married and fucking have emotions and shit.
You know,
when you get all welled up as this icon is talking about dead puppies,
uh,
we were in the back going,
hey dude,
she sucked to Elvis's Dick
that started it.
And then what happens with comedians?
And then everybody has to top it.
So I'm not going to say where it went from there,
but believe me,
20 seconds into that conversation,
I could barely stand up.
So we're crying,
laughing as everyone else.
I can't even say in the room.
It was outside in the parking lot.
It's a long fucking story
and uh,
but whatever.
And ended up being this awesome fucking Gig.
And uh,
cause the guy who hosted the show,
he did a real solid,
he went up there,
first of all,
he's the guy who's got to switch it over from people talking about dead puppies
to a,
you know,
hey,
you know what's up with a,
you know,
what's up with these fucking hybrids,
and you just feel like this asshole.
He had to do that.
All right.
And not only does he do it,
he drops the f bomb in his first sentence,
which is just,
I can't even tell you what a classy thing that is to do as a comedian because it
just totally,
it just breaks down.
It just,
it just blows the thing wide open.
And He,
and he really has to take the,
uh,
just that reaction from people.
I can't,
it's like a kick to the chest.
I can't explain it,
but,
and he totally took it.
And I remember standing,
I was standing offstage going,
you don't want a fucking great guy.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
that's like a guy who you look at you like that guy,
he wouldn't rat on you if the cops were looking for you.
He wouldn't cock block you.
He wouldn't steal your joke just to fucking total stand up,
dude.
Do you know what I mean?
And I already loved the guy,
but as always,
I never named names on this fucking thing.
All right.
So,
uh,
so anyway,
so that's what we're doing.
So I ended up going up last and um,
they just,
they were a great crowd and I made fun of people who say I rescued a dog and
they rolled with everything.
I did all my stuff about having a pimple and I just had a great time and I was
like,
isn't this great?
This really makes up for that fucking Twat the week before being such a fucking
Twat.
Right?
So I get off stage and people coming out to you,
oh my God,
it's so funny.
We were dying laughing,
blah,
blah.
Why are you 17 years in your career and you're still playing parking lots?
Who Cares?
You're hilarious.
I'm having a great time.
Right?
And then all of a sudden this fucking chick comes up,
right?
She's got her,
first of all,
she's got her hair in a ponytail in the front part,
look like Cameron Diaz,
his hair,
when she put the ges,
Ben Stiller's Jizz in her hair.
That's what she looked like.
And she comes up to me and I was talking about,
you know,
having a pit bull and how everybody crosses the street.
When I come up the street and she just goes like,
yeah,
you know,
I thought already thought you were funny,
but I have to admit I'm really,
I'm really scared.
I'm really scared of pit bulls and we start having this conversation.
And I was just like,
wow,
you know,
I've had one now,
four months.
I really think it comes down to the owner,
you know,
and basically the dog's background,
she goes,
yeah,
but you know,
you never really hear about a poodle mauling somebody to death.
You never hear that on the news.
It's like,
yeah,
because they can't,
okay.
That's the difference between owning a pit bull and owning a poodle,
you know,
is stick to capability of the animal that you have.
Therefore,
if you're a bad owner,
your fuck ups get magnified tenfold.
And rather than some mailman wrapping some gauze around his ankle,
you know,
they're trying to reattach his fucking juggler.
So,
I mean,
I'm real,
I really believe that.
You know what I mean?
Like,
I mean,
this is,
but granted,
I don't know shit.
Okay.
And I've only owned this thing for fucking four months,
so I have no idea.
But that's what my gut is telling me.
Um,
but people have like this thing now.
I think they just,
they just have this thing and they just snap one day they just snap like they're
fucking crazy.
And uh,
I dunno,
maybe I'm blinded by the love I have for this fucking dog,
but I don't believe it.
So we just keep going back and forth and she goes,
I go,
no,
it's a pit bull has the ability to mall somebody to death.
Okay.
A poodle is thinking the same shit.
A pit bull is thinking,
I'm going to rip your fucking face off.
It just can't do it.
But when it's going at your ankle,
it's trying to maul you to death.
It is.
It just can't.
First of all,
it's fucking Afro gets in the way,
you know,
like when you're fighting your little brother and you just stick your hand on
your,
on his forehead and he's swinging and wind.
That's what happens to a poodle.
You know,
if they come in with the crown of their head,
which if they played in the NFL,
they get fined for it.
All right?
Nobody ever talks about that.
How fucking dirty those goddamn poodles are always coming in leading with their
fucking heads.
Right?
But what happens,
that little poofy thing in,
in and on the top gets in the way.
It's a little cushion.
So you kind of feel that first.
Yeah.
Ooh,
is that a Koozie?
Oh no,
that's a poodle trying to mommy to death.
And then you just boot it,
right?
And it's little fucking pathetic excuse for a chest and then it's over.
You know?
Isn't that funny?
When you kick a little dog off you when they're trying to bite ya,
and then they do that shit where they still want to be tough,
but they're sort of walking away is,
is still growing,
you know?
But they don't totally commit to walking away,
but they also don't totally commit to attacking you again.
And then you just look at it.
I'm like,
yeah,
that's what I thought.
You know?
That's what I thought couldn't take it.
Could you?
So anyways,
so we're going back and forth.
So I'm not agreeing with this woman.
She's not making any good points.
And then right in the middle of it,
she just goes,
yeah,
well,
I'm,
I'm actually,
I'm an animal expert.
Like,
you know,
I don't know where she just says that.
I go,
you're an animal expert.
She goes,
yeah.
And then she just goes,
whatever.
And then she walks away.
This is that a benefit.
Okay.
I just donated my time for fucking free.
I had to figure out how to do well standing in a parking lot.
Okay.
I went through all of that bullshit,
you know,
me and all my friends had to go on after people,
talking about dead puppies and then this fucking twat comes up and hits me with
that.
And it was,
uh,
here's something for you guys.
Okay.
Anytime anybody has to break out credits
to support their argument,
they,
they lost the argument.
Okay.
Who the fuck says that?
First of all,
I'm,
I'm an,
I'm actually,
I'm an expert on animals.
Really?
And you're afraid of dogs.
You know he's a fucking expert on animals.
Is that God damn Cesar Milan,
the dog whisperer.
He's not afraid of fucking dogs.
He'll walk into a whole bunch of them.
That 42 of them that some old lady adopted and they turned themselves into a
fucking wild pack.
He walks into the middle of them and goes,
and everybody shuts the fuck up.
That guy's an expert and I have never heard him once say,
I am an expert.
He's never said that shit.
Okay,
I got to tell you this right now.
If I was an expert on animals and I was debating with a moron like me,
I would never have to bring out that credit.
What I would be doing was just throwing out all my expert knowledge.
First of all,
what I would do,
I was,
I would feign stupidity and let me Wade right into the fucking,
you know,
you know that shit where you think the water is only two feet deep and all of a
sudden it just drops off a hundred feet.
That's what the fuck I would do.
I let you come walking in with all your,
Ooh,
I watch discovery channel for 15 minutes.
Bullshit.
And then I'd hit you over the head with such fucking knowledge about pit bulls
and dogs that,
that,
that you would come up with the conclusion of God,
damn,
this person's a fucking expert.
But if you're standing there with your fucking just in hair and you don't make
one point and then you just go,
I'm an expert and animal expert and then you go whatever,
like a fucking seventh grade eight and you walk away.
You know what?
I'm a little biased here,
but I'm going to claim victory on that one.
Whatever.
Look at how I did it.
Who gives a fuck?
You know,
what the fuck is it about me?
I don't understand.
I really don't understand you fucking Twat.
I did the exact fucking thing that you guys are trying to do here.
Try to get people to fucking rescue dogs.
Okay.
And I did it and I got the biggest psycho of them all.
I went for the pit bull.
Okay?
Anybody can go down and rescue a fucking Chihuahua and go take them down to Taco
Bell and laugh with your friends as you dress him up in a little fucking midget
fur coat,
you know,
and you get the same fucking credit I do.
Fucking animal expert.
Go Fuck yourself about that.
Go Fuck yourself and go rinse out your hair.
All right.
So anyways,
let's plow ahead here.
Um,
Oh,
before we get going here,
this is something I guess I remember last week when I basically grovelled for
you people to come to Ontario,
the Improv in Ontario.
I jinxed it.
Okay.
I literally did that,
that you know,
begging you guys to come out.
Like I was doing a fucking telethon and then what happens?
Like two days later,
my guy calls me,
oh,
we got to move the date distinct came in,
you got to do this day.
But bubba,
so now the Ontario Improv Gig is off.
It's not totally off.
It is being rescheduled.
Um,
I'm actually doing a college gig.
It's a long,
long fucking story,
but I apologize because I got probably a half a dozen dozen emails,
which is a lot for me of people telling me.
I went out and I bought tickets.
So psyched to see us a site.
You're going to be in California.
I'm here to support your bill,
you know,
Yo,
your rang the bell and I answered the call.
Okay.
And what do I get for it?
I get a fucking slap in the face.
I apologize to all you guys went out and bought tickets.
I feel like an asshole.
And,
um,
I don't know what to tell you because I'm going to be ringing the bell again
when that fucking thing comes around because I don't know.
Southern California,
this is like the fucking matrix out here.
I don't even if that's the right analogy,
I don't know what it is.
It's kind of,
you know,
I've got to get on one of those Latino stations out here that'll get a white guy
on there,
learned some Spanish or some shit.
I gotta do something because it ain't happening for me out here.
Um,
anyways,
let's plow ahead here.
Uh,
all right,
here's a story that somebody sent me.
Here's the story that somebody sent me that I found interesting.
I really thought it interesting.
Um,
there's,
you know,
you got these bloggers here on the,
uh,
you know,
bloggers.
Sure.
We all do.
Hell,
I even blog for a while till I found out that my space owned them and can do
whatever the fuck they wanted to with them.
Um,
but anyways,
you know,
these bloggers,
they,
they make fun of what celebrities,
where they say a bunch of stuff.
They draw cum on their face.
They do all that hilarious shit or whatever.
So evidently one of them at something called I think skanks of New York and I
fucking know what it was.
But uh,
they basically trashed this supermodel.
I can't call her a supermodel cause I'd never heard of her.
Her name is Liz Kula.
Cohen Cohen,
less cool,
less Schoola
to Lib quietly.
It's like me trying to say that rapper's name and I already forgot how to say it
quietly.
I don't give a fuck what I'm telling you that right now.
You guys send me all that hip hop shit and uh,
I'm really liking that,
that most deaf Alma from 1999 was that the one black on both sides?
I don't know.
I've actually listened to two of the tracks on it.
And at first it was beyond me.
Yeah,
it was,
it was beyond what my year's could fucking handle.
And now I have slowly caught up and now I'm really starting to love it and I
only downloaded two of the songs.
Now I'm going to go back and download the rest of the fucking album,
uh,
legally,
by the way.
So anyways,
uh,
this list Cooler Cohen who,
does not look like a supermodel,
I gotta be honest with you.
She looks like,
um,
some hot mom who settled for less and is now sitting there going,
you know what?
I could've been a model,
but instead I married the Douche bag and accounting and I have two kids and I'm
in a culdesac and it's not exciting.
We have macaroni and cheese with toast every Wednesday.
I just don't like my life
and you know,
you know where it goes from there.
Then she ends up,
you know,
she ends up blowing that guy who hangs out in the fucking local borrower has the
cool car,
goes right back to high school.
You know what I mean?
She just looks for the biggest swinging dick she can find within our area.
You know?
And then that that's what she looks like to me.
I wonder if she's going to fuck.
Well I,
she can't fucking out me.
She knows who the fuck I am.
The Monday morning podcast.
Cunty all right.
Uh,
so this is what happens is a vogue cover girl has one,
a precedent setting court battle to unmask an anonymous blogger who called her a
skank on the Internet.
I mean,
they basically paraphrase what,
uh,
what the person said.
They basically would have to say,
I would have to say the first place award for this Skanky hissed in New York
City would have to go to lists.
Schoola Genteel Cohen,
the blogger anonymous wrote in one posting the blog since remove,
since removed,
ridiculed the former Australian vogue cover girl as a 40 something who may have
been hot 10 years ago when she was actually a 36.
So evidently,
I guess they'd been going off on her for awhile and she got tired of it.
So she went to Google and she sued to have the A,
she wanted to know who this person was,
who was trashing her.
So somebody sent me an email and was like,
can you believe this?
Fucking so and so.
Doesn't this come with being famous?
Why don't you go cry with all your money and blah,
blah.
The usual shit that they say about celebrity.
And I have to be honest with you guys,
I,
I can see both sides of this story.
Okay.
First and foremost,
the fact that she was able to get Google to cave in and to,
uh,
give her the name of the blogger is kind of a dangerous thing.
Where when cases like this happen,
you know,
it's this little fucking whatever case,
a bunch of people,
you know,
you open that door,
fucking run through the door and a piggy back on that case.
And then all of a sudden there'll be laws where you can censor what people write
and you can sue people.
Um,
so,
cause I mean the Internet right now is like the fucking wild west back in the
day.
Do you ever think about that shit?
There was no banks,
there was no fucking credit cards.
You know,
there was no mortgage.
You just chopped down some trees with your friends and your built a square with
a roof on it.
You know,
shooting Indians,
there was,
you know,
hang 'em,
high fucking frontier,
Justice,
rape,
pillage,
all that type of shit.
That's what the Internet is basically like right now.
And they're essentially,
I think with stuff like this will eventually whittle it down.
Um,
and you know,
it's Kinda hard to,
you know,
some of the stuff and obviously it's horrible pornography on it,
I'm not really into that shit.
I wish I could stop fucking watching it.
I wish someone would actually helped me to stop watching it by censoring it.
What a fucking pathetic loser I am.
But anyways,
um,
but then you can go too far with the shit because I was seeing you guys and let
famous picture that iconic photo that,
that,
that guy who stood in front of the tank and Tiananmen Square,
uh,
back in 1990 or 89 or nine,
I think it was 89 if you can believe it was 20 fucking years ago that happened.
Most Chinese young people in their twenties,
if you show them that photo,
they don't even know what it is,
what it refers to cause they basically over there with their fucking police
state is they just erase the whole existence like in a style and ask kind of
way.
We're back in the day,
I don't know.
It's George.
Um,
George Yosef.
Stalin would,
uh,
you know,
he's a paranoid psycho and when he would offer you,
not only would he have you killed,
he would have some dude like a ratio out of all photos,
like heat your,
your existence.
You didn't even exist.
There was no like documentation of it.
And that's,
you know,
that's the other end of this little cases like this that,
uh,
that make them scary.
But having said that on the other side,
just as a performer,
um,
I actually,
that,
that piece of Shit,
little fucking rat got dragged out into the sunlight.
Okay.
Because even at the pathetic level that I'm on,
and you can't believe how bad you get fucking trash to the point.
I never read any reviews.
I don't read,
I don't read anything.
I never watched any clips of mine on the Internet.
I never do any of that shit,
uh,
because people just,
they just write the most horrific shit that they can about you.
And it would be hypocritical of me because I'm a comedian and look at me,
I trashed people all the time,
so I can't get mad at it,
but I got to admit,
dude,
I don't want to read it.
Um,
so,
but this,
she's just a fucking model.
You know what I mean?
And,
um,
I dunno,
there's just like a point where you,
you know,
you're in the public eye and someone can trash you,
but you know,
they start writing shit that if you actually had it in a newspaper,
you'd get sued for slander.
You know what I mean?
To suggest that she's 40 years old when she's only 36 might not seem like a big
deal to me or anybody else.
But that's a huge fucking thing.
And the modeling industry,
and not only that,
I gotta tell you these fucking industry people,
they don't know shit about the Internet.
They don't know how to control it.
They're trying to figure it out.
And all it takes is one,
right
Douche bag with enough fucking people behind them.
And they're like,
oh,
this is what everybody's thinking.
So does fucking Twat is writing this stuff about her and she's actually
potentially fucking with her ability to get gigs.
So,
I'm not saying that the person shouldn't be able to do that,
but if you're going to do something that at somebody,
at least,
you know,
have the balls to put your name out there.
You know?
And that's what I like,
because now this person's going to get dragged out there and hopefully people
will know who the fuck she is and she'll get to see what it feels like because
then people are going to be going off on her.
You know?
Cause actually it turned out that it was,
it was one of this,
this uh,
this model's friends,
which I think is fucking hilarious.
You know how awful and awkward,
you know,
does she feel right now?
You know what the worst thing is,
is I bet she cried.
I'm so sorry.
I just that going through some things and you're just so beautiful and I don't
know.
I am so embarrassed now.
They just fucking cry their way out of that shit.
Well,
I think that works with guys.
It doesn't work with women because they cause this fucking supermodel chick.
She probably does that shit too.
Oh,
sorry.
I do coke.
It keeps the Sketti.
I didn't want to,
I look cut belly fill the fucking the Katy shot,
you know,
so that shit doesn't work on her.
You know what I mean?
That'd be like trying to use the force against Yoda.
He knows what the fuck you doing.
So I think it's great.
I hope she just fucking stairs at and when this blubbering fucking coward,
you know
cow or did I really just use that fucking word?
Whatever.
The fucking little,
you know what this,
the difference between what I do,
because look at me.
I'm going off on this girl right now,
but you know,
I don't fucking know her.
All right.
This,
I'm going to justify my boat.
I am so full of Shit,
right.
This is how I'm going to justify me.
I don't know her.
And also my name is on this podcast,
so no need to sue me.
You know who the fuck I am and then I got shit on the Internet that she could
then go comment on,
you know?
Right.
All right.
Better than that fucking piece of shit.
I don't think I am.
I think get Jesus Christ.
I think I'm the same person.
Um,
all right.
So if that made any sense.
I think it's scary that,
that,
that this case could actually start a opening a door for some major censorship
in the future.
And,
but then on the other side,
I love that,
uh,
somebody who was talking shit got caught for it.
I really liked that and I just wish I could have had a video of that girl trying
to fight the injunction or whatever the hell the legal term is,
realizing that Google was going to give up her name and just her freaking the
fuck out,
realizing,
you know,
trying to get off that track when you know it's headed right towards a brick
wall and she can't.
And then that fucking moment when she realizes that our friend knows that she's
the fucking Twat who's been writing all that shit about her.
And then she sits there going,
what do I do?
What do I do?
Do I call her?
What do I say?
And as she's trying to work all of that bullshit out,
her home phone rings and who's on the caller id?
But this chick who she called a fucking Skank,
you know what?
I bet our friend of this does fucking list.
Kula Cohen was actually talking to the girl looking for some comfort.
They're writing all these horrible things about me.
Why do people write the thing?
And that fucking Twat kept a straight face going.
I Dunno.
And then like silently getting like some joy out of the fact that she's
torturing her and she probably,
you know,
as she comforted her,
tried to figure out what part of it hurt her most.
I know it's just terrible that she called you as gangs.
I think that's way worse than questioning if you're 40 years old,
don't you?
Or do you think the age thing hurts more?
They're,
they're there,
you know,
and basically figuring out how to attack her even more.
I love that she got caught.
I love it.
That's fucking great.
All right,
let's move on.
I this,
this is basically,
and I went on a couple of these,
these bloggers sites,
um,
and I got to met.
Dude,
I,
I've gone on these,
these,
um,
some of these blogger things,
uh,
actually has bullshit.
I have in my,
uh,
my girlfriend looks at some of them.
She's into that guy,
uh,
Perez Hilton,
and he's a dude who draws the ges on people's face.
And I got it.
That's just fucking funny.
Alright.
It's childish.
It's,
it's,
it's not mature.
It's everything that makes something fucking hilarious.
And,
uh,
and you know who the guy is,
you know his name,
you know he's out there.
There's pictures of him on the Internet,
so people trash and back.
I think it's a little tit for tat there,
but if you're going to write all that bullshit and go under anonymous,
I dunno.
I,
I think there's a all right,
but why don't you say the same thing 58 fucking times?
We got it.
All right.
So anyways,
so I went on one of these,
these blogger things and this is the type of shit that people,
right.
Um,
they were going off on Ringo Starr.
There was basically,
why is Ringo Starr such a jerk?
And I just,
I already love where this is the jumping off point of this,
you know,
none of these people I've ever met him.
I thought somebody would have met him in an airport and they asked him,
they said,
hey,
uh,
hey Ringo,
can you sign,
uh,
can you sign my fucking tee shirt and can you also answer me why you've been
wearing the same earring for the last 40 years?
That long one that's hanging down like Kurt Russel in big trouble in little
China.
Okay.
That look was out in the 80s,
that fucking long dangling earring.
You look the bad guy in some fucking a Mel Gibson movie,
or at least you have the jewelry of the bad guy.
All right?
Uh,
Sony was,
it says a Beatles member.
Ringo Starr posted a video to today to his fans telling him that he will no
longer be accepting any fan mail after October 20th because he has too much to
do.
Uh,
and then it says what?
Like counting your piles of money,
sliding down a solid gold waterslide making origami hunting.
What the fuck that is?
Or if I even said that,
right,
origami out of hundred dollar bills.
And then it says,
Huh,
here's the video fucking Moron people,
right?
Like,
because he's rich and famous,
like he's got nothing better to do.
And just to Kinda,
I mean,
the guy's like 70 years old,
maybe his fucking wrist hurts from writing back to people.
Okay.
Maybe,
you know,
he's sick and he knows he's going to die and he wants to go fucking drive a
Harley Davidson across the county.
You have no fucking idea what's going on in this guy's life.
So somebody writes,
I've lost all respect for this man.
How rude and disrespectful to all his fans.
He should be kissing the fans ass since,
uh,
acids.
Since us fans are the ones who made him who he is today.
I,
there's nothing I fucking hate more than when fans take credit for the fucking
unbelievable talent of a fucking,
of ring of a star like that.
Really the fans made the Beatles the greatest fucking band ever.
You know,
like,
like any of the fans could fucking ignore what a juggernaut that band,
well,
oh yeah,
sergeant pepper's.
Yeah.
Fuck that.
That had nothing to do with anything.
If it wasn't for those fans screaming at their shows,
you know that's,
you don't make them who they are.
They make who they are.
It's not like they're sitting there and then you guys all walk up to them go,
hey,
you want to be famous?
Get up on stage,
play whatever you want and we're going to scream and go nuts.
No,
they have to fucking go into bars and they have to get booed and they have to
have shit thrown at them.
That whole blues brothers scene with a beer bottles get thrown at you or
whatever.
You got to go through fucking 20 years of that shit.
Actually,
those cuts they made when they were like 25 whatever,
10 15 fucking years of that crap.
All right.
Do you have to have the balls to walk away from the safe life of,
of going to college and getting a fucking job and no one,
you're going to have a paycheck.
You have to step off into the fucking abyss.
Knowing that 99.9% of you never even make enough to get out of that stinky,
sweaty fucking van that you're driving around in you gotta,
you gotta you basically,
you take your life savings and you bet on the fucking 90 to one dog,
you know,
that's what the fuck you do.
All right?
And then you have to come with,
you have to create something that's so fucking great that that amount of people
will pay attention to it.
All right?
You fucking arrogant assholes.
This guy is probably,
they see,
this guy's probably been answering fan mail and signing autographs for half a
fucking century.
He wants to put the pen down.
Can he do that in his seventies?
You fucking twats.
Okay,
Jesus Christ.
And having said all that,
I will be signing my DVDs and kissing babies after all of my shows.
Ah,
you know what?
I would love to get to that level where I could just be like,
yeah,
listen,
I'm not interacting with you motherfuckers anymore.
You know,
and I'm so fucking,
it's almost like he can live off the interest.
You know,
when you have so much money,
you could live off the interest of your money.
He can live off the interest of the fan base that he has.
And no matter how much it drops off because he's not going to sell,
you know,
sign eight by tens from that fucking Bangladesh concert he did with George
Harrison.
You know?
That's another reason why I wouldn't want to be him.
Sign a fucking autographs.
You know what I mean?
It's really depressing to look at a headshot of myself 10 years ago.
Forget about one 40 fucking years ago.
You know what I mean?
You know,
no one ever comes up with a headshot of Ringo fucking 70 years old putting Ben
gay on his fucking Bass Drum foot.
You know,
they always got on when he's young and in his prime.
Yeah,
he probably sits day like,
what's the matter mate?
You don't like me now?
Okay.
How about when I'm all wrinkled up or a terrible fucking does that Ringo?
Who the fuck was that?
I don't know who that was.
All I know is that was horrible.
And if you had a fucking shred of self esteem,
you'd fucking stop this podcast right now.
All right,
let's get on to some are videos here.
Um,
this is in a funny youtube video.
This is a fucking amazing video.
Okay.
And I guys,
I want you guys right now to take out a pen if you're in your cubicle slide over
your little yellow sticky things because this is a long link and this is a guy
who basically explains the banking crisis and how we're moving into like the
little robot age where uh,
you know,
some of the stuff that they're coming up with like their,
they can like grow an ear in a petri dish.
Now they're talking about some lady who had like an eye cancer of her esophagus
and they scraped off from some cells from her esophagus,
put it in a dish and they grew her a new fucking esophagus.
And then it goes all into like if you're into the bionic man and hybrid cars in
Cyborgs,
it's,
they got a fucking clip on this thing.
This is the trailer for it,
where this showing this robot that basically looks like a turtle with midget
giraffe legs,
a turtle on stilts,
like deer legs and it is running sort of trotting along.
And this scientists walks up and just fucking gives it a front kick as hard as
you possibly could to the side,
which would have tipped over any other robot.
And this thing just sort does,
just goes with it like a living,
breathing thing.
Like whoa.
Kind of like goes to the side.
Like you know,
like when a running back is,
is doing the sweep and that guy dies and he hits him in his hip and it just
knocked some five feet sideways.
But he's able to regain his balance and continue moving forward.
That's what the fuck this robot thing does.
So this dude starts with the banks and he ends with these robots and he starts
talking about how all the different versions of man have overlapped each other
like uh,
uh,
like neanderthals,
Homo sapiens and that type of whatever they,
they,
they at one point we both exist existed on the earth at the same time before
homo sapiens took over.
I know I'm using the wrong fucking CROMAC domes Nariana falls or whatever they
overlapped and that type of shit.
So with this guy is trying to suggest is that the half robot and person is going
to overlap the 100% human thing?
It is.
It's the fucking shit.
And it's not boring either guys.
Actually he keeps it funny.
So here is the link.
Okay.
Would that really long trailer,
I wanted to do that.
So you guys have time to jot this down cause you really should watch it.
It's fucking fascinating.
It's www.tedlikethenametedted.com/talks/one_and Rica has e n r I Q,
u e z underscore shares,
s h a.
R.
E s underscores underscore mind boggling.
Underscore,
knew half of you don't even give a fuck at this point.
I know,
but some of you do underscore science.
Dot.
H t m l.
All right.
And if he got lost in all that,
just go to ted.com and just,
you know,
go around the web.
So that's what I gave you was a direct link,
but you can go around the website.
I'm sure he can find it because it's a,
you know,
as dumb as I sounded the other day.
Jesus Christ.
Nia.
Um,
sorry.
What,
what you're looking good.
You're looking really good.
All right,
well I didn't know you were in the room.
Okay.
Anyways,
uh,
so anyways,
um,
what you mean what's wrong with me?
What's wrong with you?
I'm doing a podcast here.
I you just see the red light on outside the fucking bedroom door that said on
air.
I love what you just laugh at me when I do these.
See,
she has the advantage of seeing how crazy I look.
I'm basically sitting here on my boxers,
my t shirt,
and my little headphones,
like I'm doing some sort of pirate radio.
And she literally walks in as unlike a ted underscore slash backspace.
What's going on with the world?
underscore.com?
Hotmail.
You're really dating a fucking loser.
How does that feel?
They wouldn't let him do this number.
Maybe it's certain things.
They fight that.
Yeah.
Hi,
this is,
this thing is for me to trash people not to get trashed.
Why don't you fucking get Outta here?
Get outta here.
All right.
Thank you.
I want a sweetheart now.
Beat it.
All right.
All right,
let's,
let's fucking get this.
Uh,
let's get this back together here.
All right.
She's stumbling out of the room laughing at me.
See,
you hear that.
You're laughing.
All right.
Uh,
here's a,
here's a really good email that I got.
Um,
somebody said,
Bill,
if you're looking for a sport,
a new sport,
I'm gradually getting back into baseball by the way.
Uh,
I got to support my red sox because,
uh,
there are they going through the dog days right now.
All right.
And,
uh,
you know,
be one thing at the red sox were doing good and I was just like,
all right,
I,
I need to take a break from baseball,
you know,
then I could actually do it.
But the fact that they're not doing well right now,
now,
now you know,
this is when the real fans show who the fuck they are.
So I'm,
I'm coming back,
I'm gradually coming back with this guy was giving me a suggestion on a sports
that I should watch.
It said,
Bill,
if you're looking for a sport,
you really need to delve into MMA,
UFC and make an effort to become a serious fan.
I really got into it for a while and,
uh,
um,
I still really like it.
I just,
I get busy and on the road and I try to,
um,
I mean my favorite reality show is the ultimate fighter.
You know what I mean?
Every other fucking show you make a bad sloppy Joe,
when you get kicked off the show and this one,
you get your fucking ass.
You literally get beaten off the shelf.
So I really enjoy that.
But anyways,
um,
said,
I know you're a casual fan,
but the sport really is exciting,
highly technical,
and it satisfies a primal urge with mem to compete and beat on one another.
But it's in a somewhat state,
uh,
safe and sanctioned environment.
I know that 50 to 75% of the fans are meatheads and strippers.
And while that's annoying,
you just have to block that out and focus on the sport itself.
It,
it,
uh,
it really is the future because it's so natural and basic and doesn't require
any super fluid.
I don't want to say it.
So how do you say that?
Nea.
Sup.
So peripheral lists.
There's no fucking I in that he wrote super and then f you.
F L U.
O.
U.
S.
Super.
Huh.
Oh,
good.
You're dumb too.
Let's have a dumb kid
and then we'll be those parents who show up when they're going.
Yeah.
Basically your kids are more on,
no,
is it my kid's smart.
All right.
Anyways,
it says that it really is the future because it's so natural and basically and
basic.
It doesn't require any,
oh my God,
I thought I went past the sentence where this word is and I'm back to it again.
And he's super superfluous.
Rules and equipment.
It's just man verse man with nothing but physical fighting skills,
strategic acumen.
I is this guy trying to fuck me up and courage.
Beautiful.
All right guys,
you find a new thing that you can do to me.
Send emails with big words that I can't pronounce,
pronounce.
I'm just as just fucking unraveling.
All right,
let's get to the fucking youtube videos.
Um,
this is a great quick youtube video that will give you a laugh.
Uh,
it's called a girl gets answer very wrong.
Please watch this girl gets answered very wrong.
That's what you search on Youtube.
Um,
this next one,
somebody sent me this and I actually,
I can't believe I forgot about this one cause I stumbled upon this one before.
These ones are fucking hilarious.
Um,
there's one called Eddie van Halen shreds and there's another one Santana
shreds.
And basically what it is is,
you know,
there's a bunch of,
musicians go on,
you know,
up and coming guitarists and they watch all these great guitar gods and they
watched the eclipse and then they rate them.
You know,
that sucks.
I give dead five or 10 stars or whatever.
But there's certain guys I get a van Halen.
He's just the shit.
You just can't fuck with them.
So what this guy does,
he actually plays,
he plays guitar,
he gets rid of the audio,
he keeps the clip of Eddie van Halen and concert.
And then he plays the worst fucking guitar ever underneath it.
But he does it perfectly where if Eddie's fingers are moving up the neck,
the guy moves up the neck playing horrifically.
So it really sounds like Eddie is playing the guitar horribly,
but he puts it under Eddie van Halen shred.
So all these guys,
you know,
they want to see any shred and then they just get this horrific video that not
only is not Eddie shredding,
but it makes them look like an asshole.
And then people get all mad,
dude,
you should just kill yourself.
We'd fucking loser that.
He's a god.
Why would you do that?
You know,
it's usual shit.
You annoy somebody.
That's funny.
Um,
here's another one.
Another one,
funny used car ad ad is spelled a d not a d.
D.
Um,
now this is another good one.
Harrison Ford,
my wife,
my family compilation.
MMM.
Then here's another one.
This is an Arnold Schwarzenegger one.
That's great.
It's called Arnold.
Arnold is funny.
Um,
and here's the last one.
I saved the best one for last.
This guy has some sort of speech impediment.
He gets blocked.
I can't,
I don't know.
I've never even heard of it.
It's called Tono.
Tonow,
t.
O N.
O.
T.
N.
O.
And A.
I'm actually going to call in the opie and Anthony Show,
or if you're an opiate Anthony Fan,
can you please tell them to watch this video?
Because this is just right up there fucking alley.
Um,
this is one of those videos that I wish I could,
I could see Jim Norton Watch for the first fucking time.
Just just to hear what the fuck he would say.
All right.
Tonow tone.
O T.
Okay.
And um,
yeah and if you are overseas,
cause I've got a couple people,
England or whatever,
Sweden and shit who listen to this thing.
Check out the opening Anthony show on a online,
I think it's [inaudible] dot com I don't eat well.
You know,
wouldn't it be great if I had the fucking thing?
Just just look for them.
They're fucking hilarious.
And they got clips.
They have clips up on Youtube.
Opie and Anthony Show.
They're hilarious.
Look,
look for the baby bird.
That's a nice simple one to get you in into the show.
All right,
questions.
These are the questions that I'm going to wrap this up.
Question Bill,
where was your first Gig?
My first stand up.
These are all going to stand up.
Questions a where it was my first standup Gig.
I played Nick's comedy stop in Boston,
Massachusetts on Warrington Street.
I was in a competition called a fine Boston's funniest college student.
And every night,
each college had a different night and I went on,
I went up on my night and I did okay.
I didn't do great,
but I did okay.
And uh,
and that's it.
That's basically the story.
Cause I know I've told it a million fucking times,
but I was at Nick's comedy.
Stop.
Yeah.
MMM.
Hang on,
I just got a note.
All right.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
All right,
let's move on here.
This is what I sorry guys,
I'm really killing them.
I'm out of here.
Phil,
did you have to play coffee shops and bars before you could get up,
get to the comedy clubs?
Uh,
yes,
yes I did.
It's always been a grind to become a comedian.
I know you,
comedians nowadays have it way worse where we didn't have bringer shows.
Some of these dudes what they have to do here in La,
in New York,
God bless a man cause it was not that fucking difficult.
It just keeps getting harder.
But uh,
the cream will rise to the top.
Um,
did I have to play coffee shops?
Yes.
Coffee,
coffee shops,
bars.
Um,
I know I've told that story where I played the second story clear,
laid out,
Cleo,
lay down,
lay down.
Um,
I know I played that.
Uh,
I told that story where I actually did a Gig at a,
at a two story bar where I was performing on the second floor of this bar that
had screens for windows and right across the street was a carnival and you know
that ride with at Viking ship just rocks back and forth.
It literally looked like a cock going into you don't like them.
They do that horrific porno shot where they do the underneath shot of doggy
style.
That's what it looked like.
And it was coming right to the window and I was bombing so hard that all I could
hear was the people screaming on that ride.
All right,
there you go.
There's one for you.
And you know it was great.
Was the guy who hosted the show,
he actually had a lazy eye and you know,
he was really self conscious about it and he went on stage first and he was
bombing and these two people are sitting in the front row and they just didn't
give a fuck.
This guy just goes,
dude.
And he pointed right at his face.
He goes,
the fuck is wrong with your eye.
And it literally just,
it was really painful to watch.
I mean,
that guy's lazy.
I was part of the problem,
part of the low self esteem that made him become a comedian.
Okay.
And then he's like,
I'm going to become a comedian.
I'm going to get on stage.
People going to like me and everything's going to end this guy just fucking Bam.
And a,
and the dude had nothing.
He was just like,
I can't,
I can't believe you just said that.
I said it was bad.
And then I went on after that and I somehow had even a,
I had worse moments than that.
Jesus,
he's a lot of bad stories this week.
Alright.
Uh,
Bill,
when did you first open?
When did I first move up to the opening spot?
Um,
well I was getting through college,
so my first year was kind of a wash 92.
I started in March of [inaudible] 92 and I only probably only going to stage a
half dozen times,
maybe eight times 12 at the most.
And it probably was by mid,
mid 93.
WBCN used to have this,
this thing called the comedy riot.
And I want it,
you know,
as for the up and coming guy.
And after I won that,
um,
I remember that was the first time I got a real spot on a Tuesday night show on
Jim law.
Let us show,
I got a spot.
Um,
and I remember I was all fucking nervous light cause it wasn't an open mic show.
I was like,
Oh fuck,
you know,
when I'm going to open up on an open mic show,
they know I'm an open miker but now they're expecting a professional.
I was fucking unbelievably nervous.
And uh,
that was a huge,
huge fucking night for me when I,
you know,
just doing a spot on a Tuesday.
It's,
it's like that incremental shit.
That's why I flipped out when I was saying,
you know,
when they say,
oh the fans made Ringo Starr's,
you have no idea.
Like incrementally the baby steps that you take to get to a higher fucking level
and how huge little things like that.
Like the first time I got $5 gas money,
you have to doing it for a year and a half.
I actually got,
you know,
a piece of paper that used to represent gold that really has no fucking value,
but I didn't know that then.
So I was like,
I can actually go out with this $5 and get the number three at subway.
This is fucking awesome.
And you know,
I love doing standup so much that I,
I,
you know,
I would drive to Maine from Boston for free just to get stage time and we'd be
driving all the way back,
almost falling asleep at the wheel to go to work at eight o'clock in the fucking
morning to go unload trucks.
And a was just loving life and a,
it's one of the greatest things about,
you know,
doing this job as I fucking love it.
So anyways,
um,
next one is the worth of your career starting.
Can you guys hear that fucking weed wacker?
I apologize.
Um,
is the worth of your career starting to weigh out the 20 years struggle of
making it to the top?
Uh,
well dude,
I haven't made it to the top,
but yeah,
dude,
um,
it was worth it.
Uh,
the day I got five bucks,
the day I started doing it,
it was with the first fucking day when I drove home,
excited that I actually got,
had the balls to get onstage and I drove home and I was listening to doctor,
not doctor.
I was listening to kickstart my heart.
What a child of the 80s,
screaming the song fucking ridiculously pumped up in my little piece of shit
truck driving home.
I couldn't believe it.
I've failed at everything else and I always thought I was,
you know,
I always said I was going to do this and I was going to do that and I never
followed through.
And I finally followed through with something that actually went great.
And uh,
from the second I went up on stage and did it,
you know,
it was worth it and it actually helped me,
in other areas like,
um,
like last night,
you know I was,
I went down to go do stand up and these guys were playing afterwards.
He's like,
Oh I heard you play drums,
you want to sit in.
And I got all fucking nervous cause you know,
I don't do that for a living.
And then I just,
I do,
what I always do is I just think,
okay,
what's going to feel worse?
I'm going up there and bombing and sucking and make an ass out of yourself or
going home,
laying in bed,
not being able to go to sleep knowing that you are a pussy in that moment when
you could have gone up there.
So I said fuck it.
And I went up there and it fucking went great.
You know,
and plus when you get up there,
there's like,
you know,
there's always other people who were really good.
In fact,
everybody else was really good so you can kind of hide behind that fact,
which is another thing that makes standups so scary is because everyone's
looking at you the entire time.
You can't blame it on the stool.
Um,
all right,
here's the last question and then I'm going to start packing to go to Sweden and
I'll tell you guys all about it.
I'm really going to try to do a podcast next week while I'm out there riding a
bicycle around Stockholm,
Sweden.
How fucking great is that?
They you go do when you asked me to the 20 year struggle payoff,
it really wasn't a struggle.
I got to tell you,
cause I fucking,
I love doing it.
So,
uh,
anyways,
I last thing I built.
What were your stint new stand up special be called in.
Is there any way physically pos,
any physical,
any way physically possible you could save tickets for me.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
I didn't even read this.
My brother died a few years back and one of the connections my brother and I had
was your comedy and Hbo Special.
And whenever I listen to you,
all right dude,
I gotta,
I gotta I gotta email you back and talk to you about this stuff.
This is a,
I can't,
and this is really getting to set,
okay,
let's,
let's try to keep this up right.
You know that,
that's one of the dangerous,
I just read five good questions in a row.
I'm like,
this guy's fucking great and I didn't read the rest of them.
And uh,
you know,
cause then that,
you know what,
cause then that sticks me in a position where people who didn't have a brother
die are going to go,
oh,
this is a way to get free fucking tickets.
You know,
it's brutal.
People are scumbags.
Um,
which is why you got to get a dog.
That's why you get,
you gotta get a dog because I swear to God,
they just stay the fucking love you.
Isn't that right Cleo?
Ah,
course it is.
We are going to tell fucking love that God damn animal.
All right.
That's it.
That's,
that's the podcast for this week.
Thank you.
Thank you everybody for listening.
I'm sorry about moving the date in Ontario,
but everything else is a go.
Um,
I am going to be at the,
uh,
helium comedy club and in Philadelphia.
Uh,
I don't have the dates in front of me in September.
And then I'm going to be at the Addison Improv in Dallas,
Texas,
and I'm going to be going to that Monday night football game at the Dallas
Cowboys Stadium.
And,
uh,
tell you what,
I'm going to do a little thing.
I'm going to,
I'm going to try it cause I've been to the new Yankee Stadium and I'll tell you
how they compare because the new Yankee Stadium was,
uh,
was amazing.
It just,
um,
it's what the old one should have been like as far.
They never should have switched it up.
I just wish when they redid it in the early 70,
[inaudible] they could've given it to facelift without,
you know,
I don't know.
It's a long fucking story,
but uh,
but still it's no reason to charge your fans $42 for a fucking hot dog.
So one bit of sympathy I have for Yankee fans is they're really getting raped at
that ballpark.
Um,
Oh and also fuck I forgot to say this.
somebody out there up,
Natalie sent me the rams tightened Superbowl.
They actually gave me a DVD that has the,
the,
the two games they played prior to it.
I really appreciate that.
And you know,
I got,
you know,
somebody sent me another thing was just all you know,
hip hop songs and I was thinking that this podcast could be kind of a cool way
that if it's,
if you're looking for something and you can't fucking find it,
maybe somebody has it.
And a,
I will be the interface to use commute computer,
a savvy shit.
If you want to throw out your email,
if there's something you looking for,
if there's a Superbowl you missed and somebody has a copy,
I don't fucking know.
Why don't you use this podcast
to do that?
I'll throw something out there.
And you know what else I forgot to talk about was the Kegger rater.
Somebody remind me,
send me an email next Sunday night.
Okay.
This Sunday night,
say,
Bill,
don't forget to talk about the keg rater,
which is basically your refrigerator that only holds a keg,
which I did not know existed until recently.
And,
uh,
I have to admit,
I'm pretty,
I'm pretty enamored with it.
All right?
And that's it.
That's the Monday morning podcast.
God bless all of,
and I'll talk to you next Monday.
All right.
[inaudible].